c'est totalement délirant qui était pour
dire ça qui était il y a pas de savoir
qui était c'est tout le monde a le droit
d'avoir un avis oui mais le mot le mot
franchement je vais vous dire ces
arguments moi qui était tous les
Français ont droit d'avoir bien sûr mais
non c'est quoi
tout le monde a le droit tu es qui toi
alors par exemple mais moi j'ai pas je
donne pas un avis sur le divorce des
gens alors tu donnes ton avis
des années
ça fait des années qui pourraient fait
comme les gars oui ils viennent pas son
avis et toujours mes amis non mais
attends moi je déteste cet argument
typique pour donner ton avis pour moi
tous les Français ont le droit de donner
leur avis les réseaux sociaux c'est
intéressant pour ça en vrai est-ce que
tu peux donner ton avis donc toi tu es
avec qui pas toi tu es qui pour nous
casser les glaouis qui est elle pour
parler de faute grave commise dans un
divorce non mais c'est du délire il y a
pas de qui est tellement tu as des vrais
arguments on est on retombe 200 ans en
arrière c'est totalement rétrograde
Cyril c'est impossible de diriger la
politique de la famille comme ça
Géraldine non mais c'est vrai que c'est
complètement rétrograde et moi en tant
que femme je m'envoyais elle dit comme
moi pas du tout
est-ce que tu comprends le truc qui est
elle pour dire ça non non non la droite
exprimante en plus jeune femme
aujourd'hui française donc plutôt
beaucoup plus jeune que moi donc
peut-être beaucoup plus concerné par le
fait que voilà elle va elle va peut-être
construire une famille elle va peut-être
se marier elle aura peut-être des
enfants mais Daniel aussi elle disait ça
malheureusement moi je vois que
fait-elle des familles dysfonctionnelles
que fait-elle des violences conjugales
que c'était des hommes que fait-elle des
hommes et des femmes qui ne s'aiment
plus c'est à dire que il faut toujours
penser que pour un enfant c'est mieux de
grandir avec une famille ou un papa et à
maman
et s'ils doivent plus s'aimer il vaut
mieux divorce
moi j'ai divorcé avec un enfant qui est
qui était petit qui avait à peine 6 ans
je suis désolé quand je vois à la santé
mentale des enfants supérieurs aux
sentiments égaux égoïste échangeant des
parents mais moi je veux bien connaître
la santé mentale d'un enfant à 18 ans
quand il arrive à 18 ans en ayant passé
18 ans de sa vie avec des parents qui se
mettent sur la gueule ils s'engue ils
sont pas heureux qui sont malheureux
je suis d'accord avec Valérie moi j'ai
fait comme toi en fait j'ai fait un
enfant et j'ai divorcé il avait deux ans
donc pas encore regrettable c'est vrai
mais je comprends ce qu'elle dit en fait
je pense qu'elle le dit mal je pense que
ce qu'elle veut dire c'est que c'est
trop facile aujourd'hui de divorcer et
peut-être que si alors évidemment c'est
mal foutu on n'a pas envie très dur de
d'interdire c'est très dur de divorcer
comme ça c'est parce que
tu vois c'est très dur c'est très dur
parce que il y a beaucoup dur bah écoute
moi je te le dis je divorcé aussi c'est
très dur parce qu'il y a des femmes qui
renoncent au divorce parce que justement
des raisons économiques ça coûte trop
cher
peut-être que j'essaie de dire qu'il y a
plein de femmes qui restent en couple
parce qu'elles peuvent pas dire je suis
d'accord avec ben justement peut-être
qu'il faudrait se poser la question pour
le mariage c'est peut-être ce qu'elle
essaie de dire de pas se marier comme ça
à la va vite etc en se disant de toute
façon son prochain tweet ce sera sur
l'avortement
encore se marier quand tu sais que tu en
prends pour 18 ans minimum ah oui
si vous voulez encore vous marier
boutonner votre chemin
mais c'est triste que tu dis Jean-Michel
c'est quand même le concept du mariage
et de récent rester ensemble toute la
vie non le conseil du mariage c'est une
promesse jusqu'à la mort
il y a rien qui garantit
jusqu'à la fin de ta vie tu es obligé de
faire chambre papa débiter accueil à
côté de quelqu'un qui t'emmerdait tu es
obligé de manger comme le chat
du mariage
ils ont d'autres aventures amours on se
respecte ou alors on se quitte en bon
terme voilà c'est ça la modernité toi tu
es complètement on a on a un spécialiste
de séparation Castaldi 2 minutes je
pense que voilà on peut rater un mariage
ce qui est vraiment important c'est
d'essayer de réussir son divorce pour
les pour les enfants ça va être bah oui
absolument c'est vrai que vous verrez
que la première fois que j'ai divorcé la
première fois je me suis pensé
évidemment pensez évidemment à Simon et
en fait je pense que c'est un choix
égoïste ça c'est vrai par rapport aux
enfants mais vaut mieux qu'ils voient
des parents qui sentent bien avec
heureux avec des parents séparés que de
voir les parents qui s'insultent et
c'est terrible après la deuxième fois
c'était pour d'autres mais honnêtement
je trouve ça et la troisième la
quatrième
et surtout juste la faute grave elle
fait référence non pas au violon elle
fait des fans de référence en fait elle
a tromperie
parce qu'avant il y avait des huissiers
qui arrivent chez vous et sur du matin
il frappait à la porte ah je vous ai vu
ouais donc cet été en fait toi tu as eu
des huissiers toute ta vie avant
l'oseille
chez lui il crois que c'est un huissier
ah c'est vrai ça c'est une erreur qui
vient non mais les yeux c'est vous savez
Cyril c'était pas du tout je vous ai vu
parce que en général l'amant avait le
temps de se barrer avant que le lui ça
arrive mais c'était ce qu'on appelait le
test de la main chaude c'est-à-dire
qu'on arrivait dans le lit il y avait la
personne qui dit seul et on touchait le
lit à que le drap à côté voir si le drap
était chaud et ça veut dire quelqu'un
avait dormi là et du coup c'était
le tronc qui trouve le temps qu'il
trouve votre chambre le livre
[Applaudissements]
parce que tu peux te marier parce que tu
es amoureux un an deux ans trois ans
après si tu t'aimes plus tu fais quoi tu
prends perpète et tu jettes les
assiettes devant les enfants tu tapes
devant les enfants allez à l'ouest total
on est plus en 1930 et les femmes
maintenant elles sont indépendantes
elles travaillent c'est plus elle est
encore bloquée en 1950 moi je pense que
ce qu'elle a voulu dire c'est ce qu'a
dit Sophie
le mariage
ce que je dis c'est extraordinaire
non mais ah d'accord